[Music]
well we think you can brag about this
haley williams coming out for a surprise
duet during billy eilish's coachella
setting
[Music]
yeah during weekend two of the festival
the 20 year old headliner brought out
paramour's lead vocalist for a
stripped-down acoustic performance of
the band's 2007 hit misery business
[Music]
the lady sat middle stage as billy's
brother phineas and another guitarist
accompanied them for the pop punk
classic while haley slays it every time
she belts out the popular song's lyrics
this time she handed over the reigns to
billy for the second verse
[Music]
the two continued the rest of the song
together and then this happened billy
stopped singing mid-song in awe of her
surprise guests
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
totally in admiration we love to see it
i'm speechless speechless and fans
dreams were not cut short here the 33
year old singer joined in for another
duet this time billy's happier than ever
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
but there's nothing sad about this
[Music]
billy did not disappoint during her
second round this year at the music
festival singing hit after hit fan
favorite getting older also made the set
list but before she could get started
she took a bit of a misstep and ended up
falling flat on her face
[Applause]
yeah it happened just after the stage
lights dimmed she slipped landing face
first
[Applause]
she kept it real with her fans and
explained the whole thing
you guys i just ate
up here
[Applause]
i'm good
i stepped on the it was dark
ouch
i tripped on the fire thing
but the show must go on dude
what like i don't even know billy didn't
let a little face plant keep her from
rocking coachella okay let's dance huh
[Applause]
we're sure billy's happier than ever
that she made it through and coachella
weekend 2 was everything she wanted
[Music]